سابدا من هنا من حيث واقف في الميدان
النصر كما تشاهد بدا الان يتجمع مواطني
خرسون النازحين من خرصان في وسط العاصمه
الاوكرانيه كيف في ميدان النصر وهم
يحتفلون
ويبدون سعادتهم بهذه الانباء طبعا استعاده
السيطره على مدينه خرسون بالامس ايضا كان
هنالك احتفالات حتى وقت متاخر من ليله امس
كان المواطنين يحتفللون
باستعاده السيطره ودخول القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه الى مدينه خرسون طبعا استعاده
السيطره على الضفه اليمنى لنهر الجنيبر
داخل مدينه الضفه اليسرى تحت سيطره القوات
الروسيه التي برد فيها دفاعاتها الهندسيه
واعطم ان يتوقع المراقبون والعسكريون ان
تكون المعركه القادمه على الضفه الاخرى من
انها كذلك الان بعد دخول القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه طبعا في البدايه دخل القوات
الخاصه الاوكرانيه بعد ذلك همم ايضا الفرق
الاستطلاعيه من الاستخبارات العسك
الاوكرانيه
واقامت بعمليات تمشيط في داخل المدينه
وايضا البحث عن اي همم فرق استخباراتيه
للقوات المسلحه الروسيه داخل مدينه اخر
سون ايضا بعد ذلك همم طبعا القوات وصلت
الى تخومه المدينه والان تبدا عمليه
الدخول بشكل كامل الى مدينه خصوص ثم بعد
ذلك تعزيز الدفاعات على ضفه النهر اليمنى
همم
التعزيزات الهندسيه في هذه الضفه حتى لا
يكون هنالك اي عمليه هجوم مضاد من قبل
الاتحاد الروسي او بقوات الاتحاد الروسي
اليوم بالفعل الشرطه الوطنيه بدات عملها
في مدينه خرسون وبدات في استلام مواقعها
في كثير الحقيقه داخل مدينه كذلك اليوم
بدات عمليه تسيير القوافل الانسانيه
من الغذاء ومن ادويه وما الى ذلك الى
مدينه خرسون وبدات السلطات فعليه في عمليه
استعاده السيطره والاستقرار في داخل
المدينه